[Music]
thank you so much for coming to the
session speeding up research in genomics
my name is Jonathan Chevy I'm the
product manager at Google cloud for
biomedical data including genomics gene
expression and so on so I really excited
about our panelists here today we've got
panelists from Duke Michigan and
Stanford and before we get to their
talks I'm just gonna tell you a little
bit about the team that I'm a part of a
couple of important announcements in
case you missed them yesterday and tail
a little bit about what my team is
working on so I'm part of a team called
the cloud for healthcare and life
sciences team we are a set of product
managers engineers solution architects
and go-to-market that are focused on how
we can help in healthcare and life
sciences build things into Google cloud
that our industry will find useful and
increase the scale of their work within
the product team we're focused on not
just genomic data not just biomedical
data but everything how do we help make
medical imaging data more useful through
for example our DICOM API which helps
you structure imaging metadata in
bigquery or our clinical team which
focuses you may have heard this week
that our healthcare API launched two
alpha helping provider systems more
effectively manage their clinical data
and one of the things that's really
exciting about this kind of work is what
enables us to unlock when more and more
data is coming to the cloud the other
announcement you may have heard about in
Diane Greene's keynote yesterday morning
was our new partnership with the
National Institutes of Health under this
really groundbreaking partnership we
will be making many of the high-value
public and controlled access data sets
from that are funded by the NIH
available to users of Google cloud so
this will include many of the data sets
that you're already working with and now
will no longer need to worry about
needing to find space in your data
center for actually a story about this a
few years ago I was sitting at a
research university that
remain nameless and in the meeting there
were three pis that one end of the table
and there was a head of research
computing at the other end of the table
and over the course of the discussions
we were learning about the work that
they were doing it turned out that each
of the pis had separately downloaded
their own copy of thousand genomes I see
some smiles of recognition this may have
happened to you you may have seen this
happen and I looked at the other end of
the table I saw a research computing
director whose face was basically
melting realizing at how much data was
being duplicated and stored in their
data center and so these are some of the
problems that we're trying to solve both
by democratizing access to data for
researchers but also solving some of
these operational excellence problems
for for research IT leaders at
universities and other folks doing
biomedical research and also sets us up
to build some really fantastic products
so and tell you about for example one of
the products from my own team one of the
things we've built called variant
transforms it's an open-source tool you
can find it on github not only is the
code online not only the docs online but
our road map is online so please feel
free to vote on the issues and what
variant transforms does it's a tool that
lets you take your VCF data your process
genome data and import it directly into
bigquery the queries an incredible tool
a managed data warehouse solutions
somebody one of my colleagues mentioned
I think it's or 13 copies of the web
everyday so it's an incredible data
warehouse and we're setting it up so
that you can use bigquery to manage your
variant data so what does this mean in
practice I want to tell you about a
company called color genomics they're
actually right here in the Bay Area
there are health services company they
provide affordable genetic testing
focused in breast cancer you may have
heard of them so they've got this 30
gene panel in in cancer and they also
had separately an existing database of
you know phenotypic data health
information data and so on about all
these samples that have come through
their lab and they've got the VCF data
they've got this this Postgres database
of phenotypic information so what can we
do here you know there's a genotype to
phenotype problem we could probably
investigate
and they looked at existing cloud
providers that will remain nameless that
are not Google cloud and they found they
do really didn't have the data warehouse
solution that they were looking for to
be able to handle this kind of a problem
and so they used variant transforms this
tool that I mentioned they were able to
import all of that genomic data directly
into bigquery they were able to import
the they use the bigquery import tool to
bring in all of the phenotypic data and
their data scientists were able to stand
up a set of machine learning tools on
top of that integrated joined data set
so what happened they were able to do
all the feature engineering in one week
actually during their quarterly company
hack week where they get to work on
whatever they want and they're able to
create models that dramatically
outperformed an existing clinical model
they were actually able to show that
this 30 gene cancer panel was able to
predict a biomarker not in cancer which
is a publishable result pretty exciting
and possibly a product opportunity for
the company more importantly it really
transformed them from thinking about
themselves as a lab company that just
you know makes VCFs much like maybe the
informatics core is at your own
institutions and think about themselves
more as a data organization where
they're really doing data mining and
that's because of Google Cloud all right
you didn't come to let just listen to me
I want to introduce our fantastic
panelists so I will be hearing from Alex
waldrop and Roslyn Pinilla from Duke
University and then Jonathan LaFave from
the University of Michigan and finally
Sammy would hear me roar I think I got
that right
from Stanford University I'm so excited
to hear what they've got to share with
us and to lead us off Alex and Roslyn
[Applause]
Thank You Jonathan for that introduction
today I want to talk to you all a little
bit about what our lab is doing and
scaling up to the challenge of cancer
genomics with Google cloud and a
software package that we've created
called cloud conductor I want to tell
you something about the state of cancer
research that you may not know right is
that although we've made tremendous
progress in the past 50 years on
understanding how cancers arise and how
to treat them we've only scratched the
surface and understanding the true
diversity of the known cancer type star
in existence so for instance the world
war that World Health Organization
identified or it's currently recognizes
over 1,000 cancer types we have good
data on maybe 200 of those so the next
decades we'll be filling in those
knowledge gaps and part of that is with
cancer genomics and the state of Kansas
gene omics actually lags even further
behind so take for example the Cancer
Genome Atlas TCGA which Jonathan just
mentioned but in that original study it
took them eight years they took they
sequenced 10,000 tumors but just from 13
different cancer types right so we have
good sequence data and genomic data on
less than 1% of the known cancers so our
lab before you know our labs goal is
simple and that is to systematically
study the genomics of all cancers now
before you laugh so hard that you fall
out of your chair I want to make I want
to I want to say a claim that's going to
be even more audacious and that is our
goal is to do that within the next five
years now we're making progress towards
that right so this past year in a pilot
study that we did published in cell we
looked at 1,000 tumors from a single
lymphoma subtype called DLBCL but
eventually that goal is to scale up to
100,000 tumors sequenced from each of
those 1,000 cancers represented how are
we making strides on that well first off
we did the hard work and we founded a
world
a consortium of over 30 leading academic
hospitals from around the world so these
are helping us gather patients enroll
them in the studies so that we can have
the diversity of cancer types record
represented in that data set we've also
created a collaborative cloud-based
system for collating collecting that
metadata and those tumors so we can
store things like pathology data and
pathology reviews eventually we'll be
able to link up that metadata with the
genomic data and understand how patient
outcomes are being influenced by patient
genotypes but the more kind of the more
tangible goal that we'll be reaching
this year is sequencing 10,000 blood
cancers from over 100 different lymphoma
subtypes now why blood cancers for one
they're the number one in terms of
cancer diagnosis and treatment across
cancers for two with over a hundred
types they're extremely diverse and
basically we'll be knocking out about
ten percent of our goal of all blood of
all cancers by just sequencing this one
category so we've already enrolled more
than 10,000 patients in the study and
have collected more than 10,000 tumor
samples and we've already begun exome
and whole trim and transcriptome
sequencing on this project but a bigger
question is how can a group of four
bioinformaticians two and four months
what it took TCGA and there are hundreds
of by informaticians almost eight years
to do and that is to sequence ten
thousand genomes at the same time and
maybe to understand how we are saving
time it's it would be a better lesson to
talk about why it is so time-consuming
to sequence a genome in order to make
those kind of breakthroughs so it would
be really great if a DNA sequencer was a
machine that picked up a genome and lets
you read it into in like a book that
actually doesn't exist in practice a DNA
sequencer is a little bit more like a
shredder and that you put the book into
and it rips it into a billion pieces
that you get back and have to assemble
later so in order to read that story
from that bag of a billion pieces and
and by reading the story in our case
it is you know identifying a variant
that may be underlying a cancer but in
in any case the the process of
assembling a bag of a billion slices of
paper back into original book or
reassembling a genome is very
computationally expensive and
operationally complex it usually
involves fifteen or twenty third party
tools being strung together in what we
call a biological pipeline and this is
basically where you're piping the output
from one program into the output of
another they have different versions
each of them has their own runtime
environment it's a real pain in the butt
to try to get these things going and so
from a computing perspective the ad hoc
approaches that people generally use are
not reproducible they are time consuming
and they're very error-prone and so
that's why we are using and created
cloud conductor to help solve those
challenges and on our way to the ten
thousand and even the hundred thousand
genomes goal and to talk about how cloud
conductors doing that I'm going to turn
it over to my colleague Roslyn Pineda
here thank Alex cloud conductor is the
cloud-based bioinformatics workflow
management system we developed cloud
conductor to address the four central
challenges in bio computing the first
challenging bar computing is diversity
as many analysis pipelines in research
use different bioinformatics tools in
different orders so implementing the
system that allows the researcher to run
any pipeline secondly scalability is a
problem in bioinformatics as the input
sample size is continuously increasing
and the institutional computing
resources are limited
fortunately cloud computing platforms
such as Google cloud are actually
solution to this problem furthermore the
total cost of processing is also a
problem however managed to fix this
issue by using preemptable instances
from Google Cloud
and finally portability is actually a
very serious problem as data analysis
needs to be reproducible however we're
using darker technology to containerize
the tools in the pipelines so the
researcher can run the same pipeline
anywhere without having to worry about
affecting the final output after solving
these challenges cloud conductor has
become a comprehensive workflow
management system that works in three
big phases the first phase is
represented by the researcher selecting
from a list of predefined and
user-defined mathematics tools to
generate an analysis workflow after
which cloud conductor validates and
interprets this workflow
in the next phase called conductor
obtains these tools and runs them in the
correct order by users allocating the
necessary resources on a cloud computing
platform such as Google Cloud and by
generating a processing environment
using the docker system after the
analysis is complete cloud conductor
could transfer the Naza statistics
database and the final output to an
actual cloud storage system such as
Google Cloud Storage now in order to
enough renowned a lab to use cloud
conductor we implementing additional
infrastructure layer that fully
automates this entire system the system
starts from the moment the sequencing
data enters our lab at the click of one
single button we update the database
flower lab database with the new
sequencing information and almost
immediately after that cloud conductor
daemon a service that implemented that
waits and continuously Waits and watches
the database identifies the new edition
and generates a new instance of cloud
conductor on Google cloud platform and
after a short period of time when after
the analysis is complete cloud conductor
reports the status of the analysis to
the lab database and the final output
faucet we'll look later are transferred
to Google Cloud storage
and as you can observe overall the
system is not only fully automate
automated but it can also be
reproducible and as a proof of concept
where who is an early version of this
pipeline of the system to process a
large cohort of a thousand former
patients that was published himself and
in the future were planning to use this
system to increase the sample size not
only by ten times but even a hundred
times
before I close I would like to
acknowledge our lab to chart out a core
developer of called conductor and in
conclusion cloud conductor is helping
our lab create the largest cancer data
sets in the world using the right tools
cloud computing
helps small labs like ours to data
analysis at the highest attrition of
skill level and using all these systems
were able to get faster breakthroughs
develop better treatment and get closer
and closer to curing the disease that we
study we'll take questions thank you
[Applause]
and now I'd like to introduce Jonathan
la-5 from University of Michigan thank
you and good morning everyone I suspect
most you've heard of the term precision
medicine the idea is to provide medical
treatments and screenings that are
tailored to an individual's unique
characteristics take high cholesterol
for example LDL cholesterol which is
often referred to as bad cholesterol can
build up in your arteries resulting in
heart disease the usual cause of this
it's unhealthy lifestyle choices
pertaining to diet and exercise but
sometimes this can be inherited one gene
responsible for this is called pcsk9 the
steam produces a troublesome enzyme of
the same name this enzyme binds to
naturally-occurring LDL receptors
preventing these receptors from removing
the bad cholesterol after discovering
this pcsk9 inhibitors were developed
these are drugs that neutralizing
enzymes a fact that cholesterol levels
but the treatment won't be equally
effective for everyone rare mutations in
this gene can either make it overactive
or knock out its activity altogether but
by looking at a patient's DNA it's
possible for doctors to determine
whether or not these inhibitors would be
the most effective treatment for their
patient this is an example of a genetic
effect that we do know about but there's
still plenty to be learned before
precision medicine can reach its full
potential the National Heart Lung and
Blood Institute is sponsoring a project
called top med that is focused on
closing this knowledge gap but for
project lis projects like this to study
DNA they must first collect DNA a
traditional method for this is using
what's called a microarray
it targets small subsets of the genome
supplying researchers with tens to
hundreds of thousands of genetic markers
to analyze this technique is relatively
inexpensive which makes it attractive
for use in both research and consumer
services like 23andme and ancestry.com
and while this method is useful for
targeting common variations in DNA it
lacks the scope needed to find rare
associations like those in pcsk9 for
this we need to use a method called
whole genome sequencing which looks at
the entire genome with this process of
lab physically szubin TSA's short
accurate reads of DNA these reads are
then algorithmically aligned or mapped
to a reference genome and include a lot
of overlap or depth to ensure that what
we're seeing in the data isn't due to
random error the top med initiative is
employing this technique with 130,000
individuals and as produced datasets up
to 600 million variants in other words
600 million potential avenues for
discovery 40% of these are extremely
rare and have likely never been seen
before only with this level of
information can we study how rare
mutations are associated with disease
now at this point some of you may be
thinking well that's great but what does
this have to do with Google Club so
going forward I'm going to talk about
the technical challenges of whole genome
sequencing how and why we leverage
Google cloud platform to surmount these
challenges and how the cloud is helping
us foster collaboration in the research
so here's how whole genome sequencing
breaks down in terms of data size and
compute the scale of top med it produces
approximately 3 petabytes of highly
compressed sequence data and mapping
these reads takes around 6,000 core
years of compute that is a long time to
weigh and we haven't even gotten to the
science yet at the University of
Michigan we are warehousing mapping
generating aggregate data sets of Tama
data so that the genomes can be used in
Association analyses used in our local
cluster which has a few thousand cores
it would take years tackle this amount
of sequence data but with the seemingly
limitless resources on Google compute
engine we can compress a couple years of
data prep into a few months this means
researchers can start analyzing the data
and making discoveries much sooner this
convenience does come at a cost and
researchers tend to have limited budgets
but there are a couple features which go
beyond simply having the positive prices
that make Google cloud platform standout
in this result in this regard unlike
other cloud providers that restrict
users of predefined machine types
compute engine is completely modular
allowing resource allocations that meet
the exact needs of a given task these
fine tune controls allow those of us
with limited budgets maximize every
penny pre-emptive machines can take
those cost savings even further as many
of you already know TCP offers their
idle resource reserves at a fraction of
the cost but with a caveat that they can
be preempted or taken away at any moment
in order to reduce the time loss from
preemption
we have altered our pipelines to be more
resilient we've done this by chunking
our compute jobs into smaller pieces and
checkpointing the output files into
cloud storage with this approach we can
still make progress even when preemption
occurs cloud storage has also been
serving another purpose top med is a
collaboration of approximately 30
studies across many institutions each
study has focused activities and
diseases such as asthma sickle-cell
disease
atrial fibrillation and heart disease
making these discoveries requires a
diverse knowledge base so genomic data
sets like these have traditionally been
distributed to the experts to be
analyzed on our local clusters but this
is becoming more and more difficult to
handle as a data sizes increase
especially for smaller labs the National
Institute of Health is piloting
ecosystem using Totman data following a
different approach instead of sending
data to the scientist we are bringing
the scientists to the data it's called
the NIH data Commons and it will empower
researchers from institutions of all
sizes to perform high-throughput
computations within Google's platform
but even within the space data access
needs to be regulated when DNA is
donated it is often given with specific
consent that determine what it can be
used for and these consents vary widely
from study to study the data Commons is
building frameworks for access control
on top of the existing cloud storage
api's and we're doing this to ensure
that these consents are respected these
frameworks range from programmatically
generating signed URLs to fuse file
system invitations that turn buckets
into a mounted disk Google Cloud
container support is another great
feature for the second retirement
scientists love containers and it's not
just because it's easy to deploy
complicated pipelines but because it
makes it easier for peers to reproduce
your work and reproducibility is
critical in science googles private
container repos are backed by cloud
storage this allows for below two
container container images to be pulled
more quickly and just like typical
objects in cloud storage access controls
can be applied allowing you to safely
share images that contain sensitive
health or genetic information so by
leveraging the cloud in these ways we
can scale to unprecedented levels of
data storage compute a line of ethnic
discoveries and more quickly we can
bring researchers together to work on a
level playing field and in the highly
collaborative environment and in doing
so we can quicken the pace of medical
progress
thank you
[Applause]
up next we have the director of
bioinformatics at Stanford University
Sammy you're a mirror thanks Jonathan
morning everyone I'm Sami as any true
academic would do I have collected
multiple titles which I will not bore
you with today but in essence my role is
to drive adoption of genomics in
medicine
Jonathan already mentioned about
precision medicine so what is precision
medicine since I made pretty slides with
lightbulbs I'm going to reiterate the
point we take genomic sequencing data
for after patient we combined with
sequencing data from other patients with
similar disease or disorders even
healthy individuals for that matter we
analyze them together with all available
annotations or publicly available
annotations to come up with a precise
diagnosis for that patient and finally
we tailor the treatment not just based
on the disease but to the particular
genetic makeup of the patient that is
concerned so in essence we are trying to
be Starbucks for medicine so at Stanford
our vision is to deliver on the promise
of precision medicine for all our
patients and we do so by using genomic
sequencing primarily we have focused on
childhood rare diseases inherited cancer
cardio and neurological disorders so
that's the promise of precision medicine
but what are the challenges right so
there are several challenges principal
among which is that we are yet to
understand the regulatory mechanisms of
many of the genes and how their
functions correlate at a more at the
pathways level right but there are more
mundane or fundamental challenges which
were yet to overcome and principal among
which is as Jonathan mentioned
repeatability and reproducibility which
is paramount when you're using anything
in the diagnostic setting right so if
you are diabetic you're taking a blood
test to measure sugar levels if the
instrument gives two widely different
measurements at different
times that you'd make measurement you're
now going to rely on that genetic tests
are extremely complex primarily because
we use multiple instruments hundreds of
different analytical methods which runs
on different hardware platforms whether
it be laptop in house cluster are on the
cloud but yet we are expected to
reproduce the same result
not just on a given day but up to two
years into the future San the second
biggest point as that everybody and the
other panelists mentioned is security
anybody has done anything on the cloud
is primarily worried about data security
and this is extremely important when you
put patient health information on the
cloud this essentially gives people fits
and makes us lose sleep every night but
how do we overcome these challenges
primarily with the help of container
optimizer engine virtual machines from
Google and HIPAA compare the
compatibility and certification of all
DCP components helps us achieve this
goal much more easily and removes the
heavy lift of maintaining these Hardware
from small clinical labs like us which
essentially we are not experts in so
here is the example of how we have
solved it in Stanford you already have
heard about darker which is essentially
crucial for reproducibility we have our
own workflow manager of course we have
to have our own right we cannot just use
others so we ours is called loom which
essentially pulls in the understands
workflow language pulls in the doctor
container that you need for execution
step imports all the files that is
needed hashes them to make sure that the
files have not changed if so it wants
that the workflow is not reproducible at
the end of the execution schatz on the
VM and copies to all the files back to
the specified storage this way we can
ship off the container and the workflow
language to any institution and they can
reproduce the results but let's get to a
bigger problem and the bigger problem is
that any genetic caste the average
diagnostic yield is around 30% of course
for certain diseases is much higher than
30 and for certain this is slower but
what do we mean by
that like you know if for all the
patients that walk in with a genetic
disorder into our lab we are able to
give a precise diagnosis only four on
average 30% of the cases right which we
have to improve upon so I'll give you
two specific patient study examples in
the next couple of slides to highlight
the importance of adopting novel
sequencing methods analytical methods
and data mining and data sharing in
order to be able to improve upon the set
diagnostic yield so the first is example
as a patient case with carney complex
with cardiac myxoma which is essentially
Carney complex leads to benign tumors in
different tissue types primarily skin
but when it gets to heart
it leads to weakening of our valves and
ultimately requiring a heart transplant
so this is a patient case we had a
suspicion that we this is a genetic
disorder we know the gene that causes
this but we sequenced it we could not
find the change that was castle in this
patient so in addition to iluminage
artery sequencing which which we
typically do for all patients we used a
new technology called long-range
sequencing from PacBio which led us to
identify a long deletion to exon
deletion in this gene which is deleted
in one copy of the gene versus the other
which makes it much more harder to find
with Shortridge sequencing and we had to
develop novel sequencing methods in
order to be able to analyze this data
this is where the contribution of Google
ai and Google genomics like deep variant
from Martha Bristow is very critical for
us to be able to advance this process of
being able to identify novel genetic
variants which you were not able to do
otherwise right and second example
highlights the importance of data
sharing and data mining right this is
the case of two siblings affected with
several neurological phenotypes
primarily delayed intellectual
development cerebral ataxia which is
essentially you lose control of your
muscles atrophy of the brain itself so
we sequence this patients we found in
this case we found a mutation is less
and
14 Jean but which was involved are
implicated in brain development in mouse
models but we are not seeing this in
Kenya the patient so we were in sure
whether it is the real causal mutation
or not but purely by chance we
identified another patient in the
sidelines of a conference like this that
another patient who had the same
symptoms and the same mutation in that
gene which led us to conclude that this
is the true causal variant in this gene
for this patient which ended a 10-year
diagnostic Odyssey for these patients in
most of these cases these are not
curable but just finding the cause of
the disease is so much help for these
patients that that there's a hope at
least that they are secure for them in
the future right so the importance of
this data mining or data sharing is
really important because these are rare
diseases where only a handful of people
and handful of mutations are found in
genes like this so finally I would like
to conclude by raising the importance of
platforms like Google cloud and other
things even though it's not in their
core business right like you know the
contributions made by Google AI and
Google genomics helps drive genomics in
research much forward and being able to
adapt this in precision medicine not
whole lot faster with that I like to
thank everyone and invite Jonathan back
for Q&A
thanks so much all right thank you all
[Music]